hey it's Fat mental Batman I'm mark
barnard and we are here today to give
you some news news news news news news
Batman news flash news more about 9 news
[ __ ] it Batman Batman Batman be right
back
hey it's mark barnard and again a solo
episode of the fat man on the batman is
our man Kevin Smith is up in Canada
directing himself an episode of the
flash flash two electric boogaloo for
him up in Vancouver hopefully he's
playing nice with others cuz you never
can tell in Canada you think everything
is all nice but maybe it's not nice I'm
sure it's not always nice they have an
army of moose soldiers maybe I don't
know what happens up there but that's
where he is so I'm here me myself and I
next episode we got a special guess
you'll have to stay tuned for that guy
or girl that's a guy let's let you in on
that but before we get to the news today
we got to talk about loot crate why
because it's [ __ ] loot crate time
today's episode is brought you by loot
crate big old box of Awesome for a low
monthly fee loot crate delivers you a
bunch of geeky stuff you know you're
gonna love six to eight items in here
let's see what's in this episode's loot
crate it says pacific rim on it press
the big red you get a gig what a future
i'm a t-shirt to wear at the golf club
cuz you know geeks and golf yeah I get
that sure there was some awesome Gundam
thing maybe it's a model kit if it's a
model kit I mah boi because I'm about
one of those since I was nine and I like
sniffing the glue um this looks like
it's a blanket maybe of something
Starfleet Academy towel blanket shawl
it's a wrap you can wear it in public
you can wear it to fancy occasions water
bottle from ocp you know one year when
you're building a Ned 209 you get
thirsty Buck Rogers print I'm keeping
that way you can't have it that belongs
to me it all belongs to me and it can
also belong to you listen for less than
20 bucks a month lace up your sneakers
to rev up your engines september's all
about speed Batman CW's flash arrow
battlestar galactica Iron Man gone in 60
seconds loot crate Pacific Rim awesome
listen you have until the 19th of this
month to order so get to it check the
link in the description down here
somewhere I don't not up here this is me
this is all me but it's down there
somewhere more information click their
fax Luke ray for sparking this episode
because it's gonna be great thank you
loot crate for helping us to bring
people the news that they can use about
the nerd stuff that they love so much
big news item this week guess who's in
the Batman movie the solo Batman movie
with Ben Affleck Deathstroke that's
right in a cryptic tweet from athletic
you said hey maybe I'm gonna have a bad
guy maybe he's got an orange black mask
you know who it is and then Instagram
video of test footage of I don't know if
the guy was in the suit maybe just test
footage I don't know Joe Manganiello is
playing Deathstroke you know him from
Magic Mike and Magic Mike XXL and true
blood he played a giant wolf and I was
playing a giant badass created by marv
wolfman George Perez in the 80s brought
to arrow recently been a pretty badass
way listen I week at all or I could I
know how you people think I feel about
the new DC Universe movies I have my
issues they're well-known I've never
been shy about said issues but I've also
have been shy about the fact that I
think Ben Affleck was actually really
good as Batman I also think he's an
amazing filmmaker so Batman the good
Batman in a movie directed by a great
director on board Deathstroke makes
total sense as a Batman villain I want
my villain in my hero too short not to
necessarily be like mirror images of
each other but to be on the same level
and the same scale as each other a
villain we've never seen on the big
screen before bring it all about this
other Batman news you know that Batman
the return of the Caped Crusader's
animated movie with Adam West and Burt
Ward and Julie Newmar doing voices
that's going to theaters the same way
that the killing joke went to theaters
for a little bit for a day or two and
made a boatload of money way more money
than you'd have thought that movie would
have made in theaters they're doing the
same thing for that they're well
premiering it at the New York Comic Con
in October october sixth if i remember
correctly and i remember i mean just
read on this piece of paper that has the
information will premiere the new york
comic con place in theaters one night
only that's october 10th the night
before the blu-ray is released fathom
you know fathom they
awesome [ __ ] they brought you yoga
hosers right you got to see yoga hoses
in theaters with a half-hour intro from
Kevin and Harley super sweet Phelim is
doing good things for good people you
guys they're doing it for you to do not
out of love and money because it's a
business and that's how business works
but if business works in a way that
brings you the [ __ ] that you love don't
look askance at it that'll be the word
of the day askance I like that word
alright more DC movie news this is all
DC all the time see don't don't complain
we never bring you the stuff about the
DC and the Batman they cast Harry out
Henry Allen in the Flash movie now I
know I know you're all about this movie
i'm all about this movie even though i
would weigh more be about a grant gustin
flash movie we're not going to get that
so given that we're not going to get
that we have to make do with what we
have so Ezra Miller is telling the flash
and now Billy Crudup is in talks to play
doctor Henry Allen in the Flash movie
this will be he's not so much walking
between worlds but just staying within
the DC world given that he was dr.
manhattan in zack snyder's watchman so
you see how these things dovetail he's
probably not going to be naked and cg in
this movie but listen knock on wood you
can start a petition if you want to see
naked cg dr. Henry Allen I'm sure you
could get some support for that petition
because you know the internet they like
things and why not so yes this movie
directed by rick from muyiwa i'm going
to pretend i'm pronouncing that right
who did the dope dope starring shanique
more who is the star or one of the stars
of the get down he plays shaman
fantastic I will bring everything back
to the get down if you let me I will
find a way to make everything about the
get down but yes so he's directing the
flash filling in for the other dude who
left Seth grahame-smith creative
differences not everything is all
hunky-dory all the time in Hollywood
especially when there's hundreds of
millions of dollars
in the line but so rick is stepping in I
feel like he's you know the right guy
for that job like he knows how to
channel that youthful energy because
dope was all about kids and all about
kids were smart and if the flav Barry
Allen is nothing more he's a kid who's
smart so given if Henry Allen is in this
signs are pointing to this also being an
origin story and as much as I have also
gone on record saying I don't need
origin stories of Spiderman ever again I
know what that is I don't need or just
or it's a Batman ever again I know what
that is and I feel like the world knows
what those are the flash yeah you know
there's a bunch of people there's
millions of people watch it every week
on TV but there's also hundreds of
millions of people who don't and so need
a little bit of a refresher need a
little bit of a sort of breadcrumb trail
to lead them into the story so why the
hell not that makes total sense to me so
those are the three good news stories
this week those are the things we can
all get behind we all think are amazing
we all think around we can't wait to see
the last thing we got to talk about is
the bad news now this happened about a
week ago but gene Wilder passed away for
some of you like Gene Wilder was not
that present in your lives in the last
10 years or so if you're an old man like
me say born in 1843 then you remember
the gene Wilder was an icon was a
paragon of that kind of entertainment he
was his comedy was a comedy of almost
academia like he was he studied acting
like for real acting like Lee Strasburg
acting like Stanislavski method acting
like he was never a comedian who went on
stage to do stand-up he was never that
guy he was a guy who studied it and
figured out exactly how it worked and
how to make it work on screen and so
when you watch movies like blazing
saddles and young frankenstein and Willy
Wonka you see a guy who study who knew
how to make you feel and comedy doesn't
work unless you feel for it unless you
have some empathy for it the one of my
favorite stories is he was talking about
being cast and Willy Wonka and the
producers came to him and I said would
you like to play this crazy chocolatier
who
twist the minds of children and torches
them for his own delight and also to
find an heir to his fortune but he said
listen here's the conditions to which I
will do this movie I want the first time
you meet Willy Wonka to be him coming
out of his factory behind the gates he's
hobbling he's got a cane and then I want
him to fall down and mid fall he tumbles
and then stands up like I want you to
never know what you're going to expect
out of Willy Wonka I want you to always
be on edge with this guy I don't want
you to feel comfortable with him around
children but that was that was his
condition and once they met that
condition he took that role in that role
is it's it's a high-wire like it's he's
supposed to be avuncular he's supposed
to be the guy you want to spend time
with but he's also supposed to be a
little bit dangerous you know the
suspense is killing me I hope it lasts
that is what the character is about it's
about the tension between you know right
and wrong between safe and dangerous and
so much of his career so much of his
great work was about understanding how
tension works to build comedy there's
that that rule that i think was was at
least i first heard about it when
watching the simpsons of the rules of
three and seven that a thing is funny
three times and then it's funny again
seven times not funny in the first a
second not funny on the fourth fifth or
sixth but threes and sevens and when you
watch especially young frankenstein
there's the scene where he's a he's in a
lecture hall and some you know student
is ratting him about his you know the
actual Victor Frankenstein and he's not
he's Frankenstein and he stabs as he's
talking about like there was no way to
reanimate dead tissue the cerebellum is
dead and yeah we cannot bring the dead
to life and he stabs his leg with a
scalpel and it is a full ten seconds
before he says anything after that and
those 10 seconds in those 10 seconds is
the route to that kind of comedy it is
all about letting the moment last
letting it build letting it marinate
letting it let it get baked in the oven
until the dingoes off and then you can
break that tension that's what made him
brilliant that's what made him ingenious
we lost him to complications from
Alzheimer's at 83 years old and it is a
great loss for people who love comedy
who love the the business of comedy love
the science of comedy he was a
practitioner of the highest order and
and we are we are better for him having
been here and we are worse for him
leaving so this little shout out to Gene
Wilder a little bit of love from the fat
cave to to those he leaves behind and
with that we're gonna wrap up this
little episode there's there's not a ton
i want to do without the smilin Kevin
Smith by my side but I felt like it was
time to just hold it down to represent
to bring it all home for you guys at
home because why not we're all here well
here together there's some nerd [ __ ]
happening we can talk about it you can
you can come on the Twitter summit at
mark Barnard in you can come and yell at
me or adore me either 1 i'm not a
vengeful god I I take all comers I'm I'm
merciful at best petty at worst but
vengeful never so come find me come find
us in the old fat cave youtube.com slash
kevin smith will be back soon remember
next episode i had a super special guest
this person if you were to look on his
IMDB page you would find over 300
credits over a career that spam 30 years
who is as big a geek as anybody I've
ever met and we'll we'll talk at length
about all of it maybe here's the thing
we talked at length we would have been
here for like five or six hours and i am
not bad cruel i am not vengeful either
remember merciful God so we'll see you
next time same fat time saying that
channel smodcast com or youtube.com /
Kevin Smith thank you boys and girls
[Music]
hey man it's me kevin smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder